So the Blackboard component is our equivalent of the behavior tree component for the behavior tree.
The Blackboard component is to the Blackboard.
It's a wrapper around the kind of core object.
So in this case the Blackboard is the thing that the Blackboard component holds inside it
and it gives us a way to interact with that Blackboard from outside it
so we can pass information in, we can query information out of it.
Just as an example, if we were to jump to our project,
if we go into the AI controller, again this is the project you can download with this tutorial.
We don't need to go into this in detail at the moment.
I'll demonstrate this a little bit later on, what this is all actually doing.
But if we look inside our AI controller, when we perceive some actors,
we do a little bit of querying, we check if it's a pawn,
and then this point where we do Blackboard set value as object,
this is reaching into the Blackboard component on the AI controller and setting a value.
So this is reaching into our Blackboard, assigning something based on world logic from world data,
and then it is assigned to the Blackboard and then the behavior tree,
which is linked with this Blackboard, can operate with that information,
can behave based on that gameplay change, based on that world data.
So as I mentioned, it's strongly paired with the behavior tree component.
This is really obvious from even just when you go into editing a Blackboard.
If I go to find our behavior tree here, and I go to our Blackboard,
okay, from the Blackboard, maybe it's, but if you go to your behavior tree,
this is linked with a Blackboard asset, and you can jump back and forth between the two.
We've got the editor kind of like, you know,
really indicates how strongly these two things are paired together.
But even inside the actual code itself, if we were to jump to our Blackboard component,
you will see we've got functions for getting the brain component,
we've got a function for caching the brain component,
so it very much expects this thing to exist.
And even inside our brain component, I think it is,
I don't think it's the behavior tree, it might be the behavior tree, let's see.
behavior-tree-component.cpp, sorry.
And I think it's initialize component, cache-behavior.
Maybe it's inside the brain component, one second.
brain-component.cpp, yeah, right there.
So inside our brain component on the initialize component,
it expects that, you know, whatever owns this component
also has a Blackboard component class, and then it kind of assigns itself
as the brain for that Blackboard.
So you can see how much these two things expect to kind of work in conjunction with each other.
So yeah, in terms of the actual creation,
it follows a similar pattern to the behavior tree.
So you can already create one on your AI controller,
and then it's kind of already available if you want the AI to work
as soon as it's possessing an object.
And similarly, if you go to run a behavior tree, what that will do is,
as you've seen, you can choose a default Blackboard to use for your behavior tree.
You can just assign the Blackboard this should use.
So if you were to run that behavior tree,
and the AI controller didn't have a behavior tree component already,
it would create the appropriate behavior tree component,
plug in this behavior tree, and then create a Blackboard component
using the default Blackboard of that behavior tree.
So essentially, you can create the Blackboard in two ways.
You can make it ahead of time in editor, or you can rely on that kind of
again creates that runtime by that run behavior tree functionality.
And then, oh, yeah, the last thing to mention is just that
one of the kind of powerful things about Blackboard is the ability for objects
to kind of register themselves as observers.
And what you would essentially do is you Blackboard keys are again,
this kind of variable type.
So it's represent particular data, but it's kind of a struct around that data.
And you register yourself as a listener for a particular Blackboard key
to be notified when that Blackboard key has changed.
So an example of that is the move to execute task.
I think I've got that open still.
Bt task move to.
And if we go to execute task, you'll see here.
It reaches into the Blackboard component,
finds, gets the memory, gets the delegate handle,
and basically registers an observer like this.
So essentially, in this case, it's the move to task
might need to be notified if the Blackboard value has changed
either because the thing it's following has changed
or if the actor has moved, we need to be kind of aware of that.
And other examples of that would be,
as we've kind of already mentioned in our behavior tree,
we can have a decorator that's kind of based on a Blackboard condition.
And so therefore, this will need to register itself
as an observer of whatever Blackboard key we choose,
in this case, its target actor,
so that this Blackboard, so that this decorator can essentially be like rerun,
can abort, can do whatever abort behavior it needs to do,
can rerun to check for whether or not the result has changed.
So yeah, that's another place where this logic of registering as an observer
will already be getting utilized.
So we've talked about the kind of behavior logic.
We've talked about the brain, the memory.
But one of the really key components to implementing AI
is getting the AI to move around.
Unreal has its own native implementation of navigation,
which is the navigation system.
So the navigation system is comprised of a mesh
which is generated in the editor.
And essentially this mesh will query things about the environment
and generate a mesh either at runtime or editor time,
typically editor time first,
to basically do a lot of tracing and querying in a geometric sense
to establish what areas are navigable and non-navigable.
It's important to mention that this is particularly for entities
that run along the ground.
So if we wanted something like 3D,
so either for flying around or swimming-based navigation,
it's likely that you'll need to roll your own implementation for that.
It's always worth checking Unreal plugins.
It's always worth looking at FAB
because it's quite likely that something for this already exists.
But certainly the out-of-the-box navigation system, the NavMesh,
is designed for along-the-floor land-based AI movement.
As I said, it already supports static and dynamic,
so we can generate this nav data at editor time,
or if we need it to be responsive
to things that are changing in the environment,
we can mark it up as dynamic,
obviously with a slight performance cost.
And then we can also use nav modifier volumes,
which can be used as part of this,
either statically or dynamically,
and these can incur navigation costs
if we want areas of high cost,
and they can also act as blockers
to prevent navigation being generated around particular areas.
Physical objects can also affect this in a similar way.
Any time you're creating a primitive component,
so typically a collision or a visual mesh,
you can mark that object
as whether or not it should affect navigation,
and then that would be whether or not
essentially the navigation system should pay attention to this mesh
to its bounding volume,
whether it should pay attention to it
when it's generating navigable earth space.
Different navigation can be generated for different agents,
so we can have the idea of large objects and small objects
and them navigating in different ways,
being able to negotiate different spaces.
A motorbike can get through a gap that a tank can't,
and so we can generate different nav meshes
to account for that.
We can also, just whenever we're talking about nav mesh stuff,
it's worth mentioning that we can hit P
whenever we're in editor to visualize this.
This is not when you're in play and editor mode,
or it can be when you're in play and editor mode,
but only when you're ejected,
so not when you're playing as possessing a pawn moving around,
but you can just press P to kind of see the nav mesh
and how it's being generated.
That's either at editor time or at runtime
if you're in eject mode.
Also, we can form links between different islands of nav mesh
to allow AI to traverse spaces.
This can either be from heights,
so we can handle the idea of jumping from a ledge to the ground,
or it can be, as I said, through areas of distinct space
that have been generated.
We can link them together so that AI can traverse between them.
As we've already mentioned, we've covered the bare bones,
but just to go into actually how we would do this,
to actually make a nav mesh in the first place,
if we were just to start a new map.
By default, when you make an Unreal level,
it won't have nav,
but all you have to do to create it is if you go to volumes
and go to nav mesh bounds volume.
As soon as you create that,
you'll see you get this recast nav mesh.
This essentially is the runtime data that represents your navigable space,
whereas it's the volumes that mark out areas that should be navigable.
If I drop that here, you can see the nav mesh is being generated.
You can see the effect of hitting P here.
That's because I was already in show navigation mode.
If you press P, this is what it would be toggling on and off.
We get this kind of data about the nav mesh that has been generated.
We can see that mesh being generated.
You can see if I were to just expand this a little bit or something like that,
that's going to marry up there.
I can also just duplicate this bounds volume,
if I want to say this is navigable space and that.
You'll notice that even though I'm making multiple nav mesh bounds volumes,
I'm not getting more recast nav mesh data.
That's because this is our global idea of our navigable space
and the volumes represent each of the spaces that we want to demark as navigable space.
This is basically our paintbrush.
This is actually really the thing that represents our runtime data
of the fully built-up picture of all our navigable space.
Once we've got this nav mesh, there's a couple of different settings we can tweak on it.
The volumes again are just there to define areas that should be considered for navigation.
Then it's up to the settings on our recast nav mesh
to define various things about how that nav mesh is being generated.
There are settings in here such as being able to tweak our resolutions,
being able to tweak our agent radius.
We can tweak our cell sizes.
If I were to put a block, if I were just to create a cone or something,
no idea where that cone just went, just going to try making that again.
I don't know why it's suddenly having an issue creating.
I'm going to try one more. I'm just going to try a cube.
For some reason it likes cubes and doesn't like cylinders.
If I were to go to this nav mesh and then I can go to my tile size.
I always forget exactly.
Tile size on real units, is that going to be right?
If I change that to 50, it's not in our bounds volume.
It is in the recast nav mesh.
Oh, it's our cell sizes. There we go.
We could change our cell size from 38 down to something like 1.
If I change that on all our settings, you can see it regenerates the nav mesh
and we end up with a nav mesh that more closely mimics or matches our geometry.
The fact that there's a gap between our cube here is down to our agent radius.
The whole point is this recast nav mesh is bound to a particular kind of agent
and therefore it's generating the space that that kind of agent can navigate
and therefore because our agent radius is whatever it is, 35 by default,
this is going to be like a 35 centimeter gap between the, or 35 on real units,
which is essentially centimeters gap between the geometry.
So if I were to shrink that, you'd see kind of more closely hugs the geometry.
And similarly, again, because this is all these nav mesh bounds volumes are,
is to say look everywhere you could possibly here to generate nav.
It's also generating it on top of spaces.
It doesn't necessarily mean they'll be able to get here.
There's no connection between these two islands,
but these are both treated as independently possible navigable space.
If I did want to connect this, we can talk about nav proxy links,
which you can use in a little bit.
Or the other thing we could do is introduce a slope to kind of be able to navigate up there
because one of the things we can also define in this nav mesh is our agent max slope.
And we can see if I were to, for example, duplicate that cube.
And you can see it's actually going to try, and if I just scale this up a little bit,
you can see it starts generating mesh.
And now that I've kind of got an acceptable slope linking those two things,
it's made one coherent navigable space.
So that's how we create nav volumes.
It's worth looking through everything available in your recast nav mesh
to see the different settings available.
If you're wondering why there are two recast nav meshes,
that's because I have two profiles set up for different kind of agents.
We'll get to those profiles in a little bit.
But typically, if you just make a new project out of the box,
you would only see one, and it would probably be called recast nav mesh default.
I think that's the default agent profile name.
But yeah, it's worth looking at those recast nav mesh details
to kind of see what's adjustable there.
Oh, actually, just whilst we're on that,
one last thing that I should mention is,
it's also in this nav mesh data that you would be choosing
whether or not this data is static or dynamic.
So I think it's one of the settings right at the bottom.
You have a setting here, runtime generation.
So by default, this nav mesh is going to be static,
meaning it's not going to respond to runtime changes.
Whereas if you were to say dynamic on dynamic modifiers only,
we'll talk about nav modifiers in a little bit,
but dynamic is going to be this can respond to runtime changes
and dynamic modifiers only is going to be it's mostly static,
but specifically nav modifiers can have a dynamic impact on this nav mesh.
So that's a particularly important setting to be aware of
if you need dynamic navigable spaces.
You just know that that setting is there
and that's how you would change that.
And that is in the recast nav mesh data, not the nav volumes.
Yep, so that's just a little preview
of what a nav mesh might look like.
And again, similarly, you can see here,
because this has geometry
and because this geometry is marked up to affect navigation,
that's why it's carving out a volume.
This cube is either too far above the nav mesh
or it's not marked to affect navigation.
We can actually see that effect very quickly here.
If I were to do can affect,
you can see there's this tick box here.
This is going to be true of pretty much any primitive components.
So that's going to be box volumes, static meshes, anything like that.
It's going to have that setting
and you can see as soon as I tick that off,
it's no longer considering this mesh.
It's going to generate navigable space underneath it.
It doesn't mean the actors won't collide with this geometry,
but certainly the navigation system isn't going to consider it
for ignoring, take that into account
when generating the navigable space.
So agent profiles I kind of already mentioned,
but I'll just quickly show those off.
As we said, by default,
there'll just be one profile set up for you.
But I believe if you go into your edit project settings
and into engine navigation system,
we have supported agents.
So again, if you have a game
where you need different kinds of entities
that can navigate the space in different ways,
that's a really good candidate for using multiple kinds of agents.
And you essentially would just create a new agent here,
give the agent a name,
and then you can just define settings about its size.
So how, what would the default radius for this agent be?
Height for this agent be?
Step height, so if we're considering a child versus an adult,
they might be able to treat different vertical differences in geometry
as kind of acceptable to navigate over.
And so you can define a height radius.
You can even define whether or not this particular agent can jump at all,
whether they can crouch.
That can affect the nav generation.
And you can also create your own nav mesh classes.
So a particular agent can basically define a particular nav mesh data class
is used when creating the nav mesh for that agent.
So I've actually, just in the C++ for this project,
I've just done a very simple example.
I've not actually done anything with it,
but I've just created a new class that inherits from recast nav mesh
just to kind of show that you can do this.
That does require, if you were to do this,
you just need to bear in mind that in your build CS,
you do need to include the navigation system
because that's what will contain the nav mesh actor.
But if you create a separate class,
you can now choose a preferred nav mesh data that actor will use.
And again, I think as this says,
you can also specify none and then it will just choose any nav data it doesn't mind.
And you can also say for this particular agent,
specifically generate a nav mesh using this class.
So that way you can have agents that require a particular class type
and other agents that can use nav mesh data of that type,
but also can tolerate multiple types.
And so when you create those different agents,
one thing to bear in mind is that if you don't have different settings,
if you don't either have like different agent heights or different agent radius,
when you go to drag those volumes in,
you may not end up with multiple recast nav meshes.
So if you create different agents
and it seems like you're only ever getting one recast nav mesh data,
you actually need to make sure that there are meaningful differences
between your agents, otherwise Unreal will,
I guess, just infer that they're so similar
that they can share a recast nav mesh data.
So just make sure that there are actually meaningful differences
between your agents such as different radius
or different heights or something like that.
Otherwise you won't get multiple recast nav meshes.
And then for each of your bounds volumes,
you can then say, is this bounds volume only for agents of a particular type?
So there will be a tick box for each of the agent profiles that you've defined.
The default is that it supports all,
but if this nav mesh should only be generated for the common one
rather than the big one, I can tick that off
and you can see that gets regenerated.
And then that nav mesh data, this whole area will only be navigable
by agents using the common agent type rather than the big agent type.
So that's kind of just another thing to be aware of
when we're dealing with agent profiles.
So nav link proxies, as I've mentioned,
give us a way to connect independent areas.
The first example would be something like jumps.
It gives us a way to jump from a ledge back down to the rest of the graph,
but it also gives us a way to connect up isolated islands of space.
So if I were to have two spaces like this,
the way you would do this is there is an actor called a nav link proxy.
I can never remember if you can find it through the all tab.
If I go nav link proxy, that's finding a blueprint that I've made.
Yeah, it doesn't for some reason, but there is probably another way to do this.
But you can also just go to your all.
And if I just search nav link proxy, you can find that here.
And then this is an actor.
This is essentially what a nav link is, is this actor.
So you would drag this round into world.
And essentially you just need to arrange this appropriately
such that it actually links these two bits of geometry.
So if I were to quickly demonstrate this,
in fact, what I'll do is I've got an example map.
We'll revisit this example map because it's demonstrating a couple of different things at once.
But if I just go to our example map,
we've got kind of two islands of space here, right?
We have these two navigable spaces.
And if I've kind of set up some stuff in the level blueprint
that essentially just says when I press the three button order,
this AI to try and move to where this point is.
So if I just play and hit three, you can see it tries to get there,
but it doesn't get very far.
It gets to about here.
It gets to the edge of its navigable space before it's like,
well, I just can't reach that point anymore.
I'm as close as I possibly can be, but I can't reach there.
So if we put in, I've got a pre-made nav proxy here.
If I just kind of snap this down to the floor,
you can see the nav mesh regenerates.
And that's because I've made a kind of like a link between these two islands.
This is a specific actor that I've made,
but really this just inherits from nav link proxy.
I'll explain why I've made that nav link in a minute,
why I've made that actor in a second.
But just for now, you can see now that I've connected,
now that I've brought that nav link down and kind of connected it up with the mesh,
it's now like treated as a kind of valid connection.
So if I were to kind of lift that up and away,
I don't know how close it has to be exactly,
but you can kind of see the arrow gets generated right when it's close enough,
when it's no longer close enough.
That's just hanging around now.
If I just want to play, sorry, just clicking the wrong things.
Yeah, you can see that that's, for some reason,
the debug arrow is kind of hanging around there,
but that's no longer navigable space.
And there's a certain point at which this is now kind of like,
and you can see the nav mesh reacting to it, right?
So it's too far away,
won't be treated as kind of an acceptable link
and once we're close enough, now it is.
So the way you work with a nav link proxy is you,
again, this is just an actor you can drag into the level.
You can make blueprints that inherit from it,
as you can see that I've done.
And then essentially it's just these two point links.
A nav link can also represent multiple links at one time.
So it's not just a one to one.
You can have a nav link that kind of represents a web of connections.
But by default, it's going to be just two points.
And it's got like a kind of left point and a right point.
And you essentially just manually author these points.
So you'll see, as I change these values,
I've got this, you can literally see the connection changing.
So you would just, if this is meant to represent a jump,
obviously you could just manually author this to be like,
have a certain amount of vertical transition between them.
And that's kind of all there is to it.
Then you can similarly mark up here, which agents is it suitable for?
How far should it project up and down?
So that's essentially going to be like,
you know, if it's a little bit above the nav mesh,
is it still going to try and find a nav mesh within this much vertical distance
that it can be a suitable link for?
And then also this idea that the, you know, is it a nav link?
Is it one directional?
So something like a jump, obviously you shouldn't be able to navigate back upwards up that cliff.
It's kind of one directional.
So you can choose, is this a nav link that is suitable for both directions,
or is it left to right or right to left?
And I suspect we'll get an update in the arrow that kind of demonstrates that,
that it will kind of only work that one way.
Now, the other thing to mention about this,
and this is the kind of like reason I've made a blueprint here,
is we've got this kind of more complicated form of nav links,
of nav link proxies, which is called smart links.
So with simple nav links, with the kind of standard nav link,
that's kind of static data that is built in at edit time.
If we need something that is a little bit more nuanced, a little bit more dynamic,
that's where smart links come in.
Smart links basically give us the same capabilities of nav link.
They are part of the nav link proxy,
but they give us the ability to essentially turn this functionality on and off.
If a nav link proxy is utilizing,
because again, any nav link proxy actor you make is kind of both at the same time.
They've got the simple link and the smart link category.
If it is a smart link as well as a normal link,
then it will prefer to use the smart link if they seem to have the same connections.
You can copy the kind of functionality of the basic points over to the smart link.
When you look in the smart link section,
we've got a link relative start and a link relative end.
This works in exactly the same way that our left and right do here.
But if you've authored a simple link,
then you need to convert it to a smart link.
If I change this connection a little bit here,
you'll see there's just this handy editor button
that essentially just copies that left and right data
into our link relative start and link relative end.
Otherwise, these do exactly the same job.
You can see as I tweak this,
you can see it's changing this kind of second set of data,
and this represents the actual smart link, not the simple link.
Smart links, the same functionality here.
You can affect which directions it's for, whether it's both,
whether it's one way or the other.
You can check whether or not it's for a particular area, classes,
and then you can turn this link on and off.
You can see as I turn that off,
we get this different arrow color, so this is no longer a usable link.
Obviously, in this situation,
because we've also got a setup here for our default point links,
then it's kind of both.
But if I were just to delete that,
this is only a smart link.
This is not usable,
so our actor would simply not be able to use it.
And if I were to set that as enabled, now it can.
But this is also a change that you can make at runtime.
So if I were to, I can just get my smart link component
and just do set link enabled.
I can never remember the function name.
Enabled.
Hmm, might be valid.
It's, yeah, sorry, I lose the terms.
If I just look up smart link.
Okay, sorry, it's built into the nav proxy itself,
not the component, my apologies.
But either way, set smart link enabled,
this is the function on the nav link proxy itself,
and you can use that at runtime
to toggle whether or not that's enabled.
So that's kind of one component of it.
But the other kind of useful thing to be aware of
is once you're using smart links,
things can be notified that that smart link is either available or being used.
So one of the things I've done when working on games myself
is I've actually used this event that you can build into smart links.
This smart link reached to let us know when that link is being used.
So you can see that we're getting a print string
when then the agent has started using that.
This same thing wouldn't happen if we weren't using a smart link.
So that's unique behavior provided by utilizing smart links.
And you could use that for any number of useful bits of information.
You could play certain animations in this context.
In working on games previously, we've used it,
we essentially made door actors that were smart links,
and we got notified when the AI wanted to use this door.
We would kind of lock that door off so other actors couldn't use it,
so we couldn't have two actors passing through this door at once.
And then we would kind of enter a pre-canned door opening animation
to make the hand nicely marry up to the door handle
and kind of navigate through that.
That's an example of all the different capabilities and power
that these smart links provide us.